today I'm going to take you on a island
tour that will help you see and passing
through my eyes the eyes of a
six-year-old kid and here is the great
white shark is a whale shark there they
are
my a my a 2 inch iov and even the Blue
Marlin people of the internet retro
raconteur here your guide to
family-friendly content in the world of
video games I'm here today with my
six-year-old son who's a huge fan of
Animal Crossing
what about Hamlet do you like so much
that's all he talked about right there
he is let's see what he says about me
talk about me Hamlet oh yeah you're
right I was digging up fossils for sure
guys why are they gonna crack up because
it's a a hand for name hey fish aren't
down here what are you doing I'm going
to see the fossils no fossils first limo
is so dark in here never seen gonna
start he's that guy a little woody
Plesiosaurus oh that really is a good
attempt close close
yeah there he is we got him complete
when only that let's go to that
Spinosaurus you can follow that CT and
he looks so weird he does a pretty weird
without its head yeah
I know that poop I know it's there wait
what did you just say that looks like
poop really
are you kidding me okay we've been
wondering about this for so long I got
to look this up we were right it is
actually dinosaur food but that has been
fossilized yeah you know sharks are in
ain't no more crossing okay here's the
huge diamond sturgeon it's a big fish
man yeah they almost all of these are
about the donated by me actually
oh really don't know about you yeah
watch it what do you want a cookie or
something okay giant snake AVG in the
door there you see up there that is
snapping Turk why do you see him up
there and odorous one huge dry to air
upon goodness yeah when you come to got
around you really you see everybody to
see him Jerry your arrow point
Wow and here it is so great white shark
is a whale shark there they are my money
to anchovy and even the Blue Marlin
goodness joint trevally to and when we
didn't even have a lot of guys horse not
close to let myself but then huge guys
came and the sacrifice from the teeth
right on it really right and then here
comes see you can in the orifice I mean
your your pronunciations are better than
a lot of adults I gotta say for fish and
there is the football says in the
ceiling for me an twins raining
actually wants to see some greater
specialization let's do it greatest
fisherman huh not looking at my pole so
weird and you can kill that shark
Surinam crossing looks like a cool girl
man ready seeing its flower section if
you walk through here's a lot of fruit
trees it's like a path to secret but
don't worry that there's a wonderful you
don't think it's a Dorado
see I told you righto here is a sign
that means the house is this way
no the house we called it the Frog how'd
you know it was a frog Jana they're like
medium small triangle all right let's go
up and give people a tour of your house
what do you say and here we go
what is this room right here we walk
right into your house you got a lot of
stuff in here son
it's teaching a double-door good name
should I change what you can change
clothes
yeah what in our fridge that doesn't
make any sense
no the bedroom okay I see Wow look at
that trophy case man well uh you can get
a recipe from it a DI Y and then you can
do it you need only three gold nuggets
oh yeah you're right three gold nuggets
six iron nuggets though and 24 hardwood
did it take you a while to get all that
yep that's it chops and changed okay so
what else no no no no what else we got
in this room here what is going on with
this wall so Sharon tickets I think Oh
Sahara yeah yeah the camel who comes to
visit you got the tickets from her and
then now this special wall that she what
is that wall is that what I think it is
mm-hmm
is that chocolate that's an that wall is
actually chocolate can you go take a
bite of it
no that'd be pretty funny too good what
about that chair right there is that a
baseball glove yeah your Nintendo switch
in there hmm
also a microscope I like your light what
is that light
is that from the light from Pixar
I got 14 guys bowling lane okay it looks
like world Pixar lamp to me just a
little bit bigger though it ready for
the fish swimming what in the world is
no you do not have great white shark in
your house the model from your CJ I mean
like they're riding a giant trevally are
you serious you caught the giant
trevally how many times have you caught
that oh how many times have I caught it
here oh yeah yeah see see guys he likes
to rub it in
he likes to rub it and I still don't
have huge fish like Cedars you can see
we got a little pond here and they see
the campsite really neat read your faith
in your dog here's a dog okay I'm gonna
go in the swim yeah yeah okay is leaving
off of the campsite alright if you enjoy
playing Animal Crossing with your kids
and want to see more videos like this
and please consider hitting that
subscribe button and know that we
already have a ton of animal crossing
videos on the channel here to let you
know how to do things like give your
eyelids 5 stars
or how to conquer the stock market thank
you so much for watching we'll talk to
you again soon thank you so much